new push to help fight the coronavirus
americans can now order free at home
coveted tests through a government
website called
covidtest.gov
it's part of president biden's promise
to improve testing as the omicron
variant spreads but critics say it is
not nearly enough ed o'keefe is at the
white house for us ed good morning to
you new government website does not
always inspire confidence what do we
know well good morning as you said every
person now can order up to four free
tests for a residential address the
website name bears repeating
covatests.gov
has been eagerly anticipated ever since
president biden announced a plan in
december to ship half a billion at-home
tests to americans last week the
president doubled the country's order
with plans now to eventually provide a
billion of them to households nationwide
the website had a soft launch yesterday
and there were isolated reports of
problems with the address verification
part but no significant issues have been
reported as of this morning and once
tests are ordered it won't be a rapid
turnaround officials say the u.s postal
service typically ships the tests within
7 to 12 days this comes as the biden
administration is also announcing plans
this morning to start shipping 400
million n95 masks starting at the end of
this week they're coming out of the
strategic national stockpile and will be
available at community health centers
and pharmacies across the country where
millions are already getting tested and
receiving vaccines we'll get more
details on this later today when the
president holds his first solo news
conference of the year
thank you so much